أجنبي أجنبي
وقد تكون على حق عندما
تنظر إليهم، تدرك أن البعض منهم
تشير قرونهم إلى الأعلى
بينما البعض الآخر يشيرون إلى
الأسفل، لذلك تقول حسنًا دعنا
نقسمهم إلى فئتين ربما هذا
سيجعل الأمر أسهل بالنسبة لي
الآن، لقد بدأت في ذلك  لاحظت بنفسي المزيد من
الاختلافات،
وفجأة أدركت أن كل ما
تفكر فيه هو هذه الاختلافات التي
كرست لها الكثير من اهتمامك
بحيث لا يمكنك التوقف
للحظة وتقدير مدى الاختلاف الذي
يمكن أن يكون بين أفراد نفس القبيلة.
ألقِ نظرة على هذين الاثنين، على سبيل
المثال، لديهما
هياكل جسمية مختلفة تمامًا وأنت تدرك ذلك
ولكن نظرًا لأن الكثير من تركيزك الآن
يدور حول شكل القرون،
فمن قد يبدأ في التقليل من أهمية
الاختلاف داخل كل فئة
أو أي مخلوق آخر  لقد رأيت بعد
تجربة تلك المادة القانونية الجديدة،
اتضح أن عقلك يقوم دائمًا دون وعي
بتنفيذ عملية
التصنيف هذه على جميع أنواع
المحفزات كمثال
أساسي ولكنه مثير للدهشة بعض الشيء،
فلنأخذ قوس قزح
الذي كما نعلم يتكون من  سبعة
ألوان صحيحة،
إلا أنه ليس
إذا سألت عالم فيزياء على سبيل
المثال، فمن المحتمل أن يخبرك
بشيء على غرار وجود
عدد لا نهائي من الألوان بين 400
و700 نانومتر،
وبالتالي بدلاً من تحليل كل
الأطوال الموجية المميزة في مثل هذا العدد
اللانهائي  الطيف،
سيكون من المنطقي تقسيمها
إلى عدة فئات
، وفي الواقع هذا هو بالضبط ما
يفعله العقل الباطن
ولكن كما رأينا يحدث من قبل،
يؤدي هذا إلى بعض العواقب غير المقصودة،
أي أننا
نبدأ في التقليل من أهمية الاختلاف
داخل كل فئة، على سبيل المثال
نعتقد  أن جميع ظلال اللون الأحمر هي
نفس الشيء
بينما نبالغ في مدى
اختلاف الألوان عن بعضها البعض،
على سبيل المثال، نعتقد أن اللون الأحمر والبرتقالي لونان
مختلفان تمامًا وفشلنا
في رؤية كيفية اندماجهما مع بعضهما البعض
تمامًا كما تفعل ظلال اللون الأحمر المختلفة.
في الأشياء ليست هي الشيء الوحيد الذي نقوم
بتصنيفه،
والأهم من ذلك أننا نميل أيضًا إلى فعل
ذلك للأشخاص،
وهذا ليس أمرًا سيئًا دائمًا، على سبيل
المثال، إذا رأيت شخصًا يرتدي
شارة وزيًا أبيض، فسوف
تصنفه على الفور على أنه
ضابط شرطة وهو ما  سيخبرك أنه يمكنك
طلب المساعدة منهم إذا كنت في حاجة إليها
وربما التفكير في أن جميع ظلال اللون
الأحمر متشابهة، وهذا ليس ضارًا بفكرة
خاطئة
ولكن ماذا يحدث عندما نطبق ذلك على
جميع الأشخاص من عرق معين  مثال
ألا يمكن استخدام ذلك لتبرير الصورة
النمطية القاسية عنهم، أو حتى اختزالهم إلى
شيء أقل من الإنسان
لإنهاء الأمر، أود أن أروي قصة كنت فيها
أنا نفسي مذنبًا بهذا
التحيز التصنيفي،
الحدث
أجنبي أجنبي
أجنبي
بدأت أنظر إلى بلدي  الافتراضات الخاصة بي
ومحاولة معرفة ما إذا كنت قد
استسلمت لأي تحيزات على وجه التحديد
التحيز التصنيفي.
بعد ذلك، أتحدى هذه الافتراضات من خلال
سؤال نفسي
كيف أفكر، وكيف سأفهم
الموقف إذا تبين أنها غير
صحيحة بهذه الطريقة؟  نعكس في
تلك الافتراضات
معنى أكبر
لتلخيصه عندما
ننشئ فئات لأنفسنا دون وعي
لتبسيط الحقائق المعقدة في العالم،
وننسى التنوع المذهل
الموجود هناك،
وننسى أن المفاهيم والأفكار تشبه إلى حد كبير
الألوان في قوس قزح تمتزج مع بعضها
البعض ل  تشكل سلسلة متصلة ضبابية
مربكة وغير واضحة
فقط من خلال قبول هذا الواقع، هل يمكننا أن
نبدأ في معاملة الناس بشكل أكثر عدلاً
وبمزيد من التعاطف
وبمعنى أكثر عمومية،
أعتقد أننا يجب أن نحاول النظر إلى
فوضى العالم
واحتضانها.  للتفكير بعمق في مدى
استمرارية كل هذا،
واستكشاف عالم حيث
يتم تحدي افتراضاتك والسباحة وسط
فوضاه، شكرًا لكم
[تصفيق]